what's up guys my name is Colin McNeill
for the score eSports you know there's a
reason they call faker the unkillable
demon king this guy goes beyond titles
like Series MVP or even world champion
this guy is the league of legends goat
from his incredible out plays to his
surgical team fighting skills here are
the best plays from fakers competitive
league of legends career during the 2016
World Championship semi-finals
the Rox Tigers took SKT to a climactic
Game five while they fell behind early
gorilla
smeb and peanut looked like they were
going to catch the star mid laner out in
top lane with an incredible dodge on
penis cocoon and only using his ghost
summoner spell faker manages to get away
denying rocks the kill on the way to his
third world's title for sync the cocoon
- ever so slightly miss this leaf
villain exposed to crazy defense but
that was so close as one of the world's
most dominant laners faker often finds
the slimmest openings to solo kill his
lane opponents Katie's nog nee was
trapped under the turret by fakers Riven
and with wolf coming out of the jungle
faker had all the support he was going
to need after a flash to counter nog
nasone and an incredible sidestep to
dodge the Cassiopeia halt Baker managed
to walk out with the kill arabesque 18
dodged that petrified haze so
beautifully I almost couldn't see it
after getting caught by the cocoon from
Katie's score and getting dropped to
less than 1/4 health Baker landed a
defensive ultimate to push out high
cheney's Alistar after turning back onto
score
faker used his zhonya's hourglass to
give his tank time to enter the fight
with the numbers advantage Baker and SKT
managed to turn the tide looks like he's
gonna fall as well and he does
are barely coming out alive and skg
finds another Jew killed at SK Telecom
continue to inch forward above KT in
another match against Korean rivals kt
rolster the two teams were locked in a
back-and-forth teamfight in the barren
side river that is until faker blew the
fight wide open catching an already weak
nage an arrow with his syndra ultimate
faker landed his E and Q on both players
killing nog day before finishing off
arrow with an auto attack coming out of
nowhere with the flash right there no
ignite up at all and catching that look
log saving his ultimate to actually make
the play right there at the 2014
all-star Paris tournament SKT found
themselves up against fnatic with two
players down for SKT fnatic decided it
was time to push baron
faker dove into the bear pit managing to
find a quick kill onto the enemy jungler
before jumping back across the wall with
the rest of SKT there to support him
faker
jumped back in and finished off both the
Baron and expec a to win the fight
he's gonna get drop that what supply by
by the season three champion during
their first world 2017 group stage match
SKT faced off against cloud nine after a
pretty passive nine minutes contracts
decided that it was time to put the
pressure on faker but you just don't do
that to the unkillable demon king
landing a quick ultimate and a perfectly
time flash under his own Tower
faker managed to not only get away but
find the kill on the contract super
clean out play there you wait and until
the wreck site shows for the ultimate as
he's coming forward as she is coming
board then you flashy to dodge the
damage Baker never scared for his life
there with Baker's dominant Lane
presence in this 2016 summer split
matchup against CJ entus SKT have
already taken two of the middle lane
towers with only the inhibitor turret
left three players attempted to hold off
the siege from SKT but Baker had other
plans sue and faker with the big play
inner tower 102 and take you tell this
inhibitor to boot
SK Telecom good board welcome back down
12 kills 2-1 and facing a 4v5 situation
with Katie's fresh Baron buff faker
managed to land an incredible shock wave
with Orianna getting a triple kill and
helping SKT turn
absolutely devastates the ranks of kt
rolster a triple killer hip pod trying
to get out with his life but it just
doesn't cook very lightly SKT found
themselves behind the eight-ball early
against Edward gaming in their second
group stage game at Worlds 2017 with
Baron and dragon about to spawn EDG were
grouped up in the mid lane that's when
SKT
initiated an explosive teamfight faker
landed his shockwave on four of EDG
players killing Mako in the end SKT
managed to kill four players and regain
control of the game for their second
group stage
[Applause]
[Applause]
our number-one entry on this list is one
of the best-known and most viewed plays
in League of Legends history
fakers ed out play against Ryu is
arguably the moment that catapulted him
to international fame now a lot has been
said about this incredible play over the
years so let's let fakers near
superhumans speak for themselves
Wow kind of humbles you to see play at
that level doesn't it now it's got to be
said with a player as legendary as faker
is there were a ton of awesome place to
choose from and if you think we missed
one in our list let us know in the
comments section below thanks for
watching if you want more great content
just like this be sure to hit the
subscribe button